- America, what happened?
Why did this whole debacle
of a election occur?
(upbeat music)
- What I know about Donald Trump
is that he has terrible hair.
- Angry orange orangutan thing.
- You know, he's scary,
he's actually really scary.
- He's racist.
- Most people my age
think that this is a joke.
- Maybe Americans are too
used to reality television.
- I lived in Toronto in
2010, which is when Rob Ford
was elected mayor, and
this feels very similar.
- I love reality TV, but
I just wouldn't think
that anybody from Vanderpump Rules,
for example, would go run for office.
- We were all, in Toronto,
we were all really sure
that Rob Ford could not and
would not ever be elected mayor.
- Do you think this is funny?
- As a Canadian I'm a
little surprised by it.
- People were encouraging Rob Ford to run
'cause they thought it would be funny.
- Are you planning to move
to another part of the world?
- Running to Canada.
- Where are you gonna live in Canada?
- If moving is not gonna
solve your problems,
mainly because you know
you're right next door,
Trump will be right next door.
- So it's not a guarantee of escape.
- Dear Americans,
- Make sure you vote,
because your vote counts.
- It's time to be vigilant
and to participate.
- Do whatever it takes,
fight 'til the end.
- If you need us, we're there for you.
- Good luck, to all of us.
(upbeat music)
It's not funny.
I know.
Laughing 'cause it's scary.